jason oppenheim and christelle styles
are going their separate ways on
thursday jason confirmed he and
christelle split after five months of
dating he wrote on instagram quote while
we have different wants regarding a
family we continue to have the utmost
respect for one another adding having
her in my life is one of the best things
that has ever happened to me you know
what's interesting as i've never had a
situation happen before where i became
best friends with someone first jason
and chriselle's relationship began as
both co-workers and co-stars jason owns
the oppenheim group where christelle
works as one of the agency's high-end
realtors i would like world peace
well then you don't want to work at the
which
oppenheimer
course fans have seen play out across
four seasons of selling sunset on
netflix we have just such deep trust and
respect that i just it doesn't if
there's one person on the planet i think
i'd be comfortable
putting my relationship out there with
on camera it's hers the pair first
confirmed their romance over the summer
sharing these pda filled vacation photos
to instagram the breakup news comes
shortly after their relationship became
on-screen official in a sneak peek for
season five of the hit reality series
did you guys hear the news
no less news
it's insane to me i don't know what to
say i knew before they told me so weird
though but like exciting but like so
right i'm not getting into that you know
we're not criminals we're not doing
anything wrong
prior to the romance christelle was
married to this is us star justin
hartley the actor filed for divorce in
2019
it was finalized in february meanwhile
jason previously dated another co-star
and realtor mary fitzgerald i mean this
is the most kind of fulfilling and
rewarding relationship i've ever been in
both jason and krishel opened up to et
recently about the romance has getting
romantically involved complicated the
work at all or not because you kind of
you know this how to do this because of
the miriam at all i mean it just made it
better because you know we
we get to discuss we talk we have so
much in common obviously so we get to
talk about work when we're at home
um
but no i it hasn't complicated it
at all i mean let's be honest michelle
and i share the same best friend so
whether or not krishna and i were
together we'd probably be around all the
time anyway it's not all drama on this
show though because
there's some love
you and jason seem to be doing really
good
how you know
why does your relationship work with him
you know what's interesting as i've
never had a situation happen before
where i became best friends with someone
first
and it's just been so kind of freeing
i'm my complete whole self good bad and
different whatever and
it's it's the best way to do it because
we knew everything about each other we
worked so well together we have so much
respect for each other
so i think that that is a really good
formula to start a relationship